hi good afternoon this has been a
tremendous pleasure listening to a very
rich presentation this afternoon there
are so many things that I learned and
they would like to comment on that I
might actually claim an hour for myself
but that would be impossible so let me
say that one of the things that came to
mind listening to the discussions even
starting with mr. else's presentation on
the China's economic might if one can
summarize the lessons of these talks one
can say 14 trillion dollar plus China
dream equals expanding sovereignty let
me explain what I mean Chinese economy
has grown since the launch of the for
modernization and has now surpassed in
United States in PPP term and what is
the practical consequence of that
economic rise is massive expansion of
Chinese military not just Chinese
economy and Chinese ability to influence
economy all over the world so when long
says that some areas of Vietnam had
become Chinese exit oriole
extraterritorial area that is because
Chinese have the money to invest and
Vietnamese have no other option but we
invite the Chinese in that territory to
exploit Chinese capital and give their
workers jobs Chinese buildup of their
fishing fleet giving each Fisher fishing
boat a five-thousand-dollar GPS device
to connect to the Chinese Navy Central
Command it can do that because they have
the money so ultimately Chinese 14
trillion dollar economy connected with
Xi Jinping's China dream which means
bring China back to the ol
glory that is of course somewhat
fictional but China dominates East Asia
and let us bring China to that position
by using China's massive economic and
military power so that is what is
resulting in China's expansion
sovereignty claims now that being the
case I think Harry has pointed out using
xem fair to counterpoint in China but
Chinese attempt at controlling Southeast
Asia controlling South China Sea doesn't
really depend on just military power it
is a totally moot effort to take control
first by saying that this area is
traditionally Chinese area Chinese
fishermen have always been there and I
in fact have seen in 1995 a Chinese
publication used the word leben from the
Chinese people lebensraum requires them
to have the South China Sea as to
produce their fish so this one aspect of
lemon from required by the Chinese then
it expands to the question of energy
resources we need to feed our economic
engine and then when you have the
resources then we can actually go and
take over I have covered Southeast Asia
and South China Seas for the last 40
years and I have a hard Chinese
officials say in the 70s it is no
problem we can dissolve it by a lateral
talks we can put the question of
sovereignty aside and let's jointly
develop Southeast Asia South China Seas
but the sovereignty question will be
discussed later
and that was what I think was implicit
in tongues shoppings word that let's
hide our capabilities and bite for our
time so bite for your time is when you
can actually exercise sovereignty and
you don't have to discuss it with
anybody so this is our territory and we
take it and so that is what Chinese have
done and I think the question of
military stopping China it becomes
impossibility because they are already
are well entrenched in most of the
features that are above water
diplomatically they have made a huge
gain just two weeks ago Chinese Foreign
Minister Wang Yi was in Los he declared
that Laos Cambodia and Brunei have
agreed to put South China Sea question
to bilateral talks that was a basically
breaking of ASEAN Sen position has been
that South China Sea issue has to be
discussed in a multilateral way and
bilateral issue as well and settlement
was being refused but by bringing the
three countries of ASEAN outside the
seein consensus and making a declaration
it is basically China showing that they
are not interested in using ASEAN as a
group for their diplomatic purpose
they're happy to bring it up so that the
the I think Eileen's point about the
quandary that Philippines faces dealing
with China that is the quandary phase by
all ASEAN countries because they are
especially Cambodia Laos Burma they are
psychologically so weak that in a few
billion dollar Chinese air and
investment would go a long way to
improve their life so and since they
have no direct stake in South China Sea
it is easy to
no corral them into supporting Chinese
position and finally I would point down
to make that Harry mentioned that Trump
like focus on on issues that you are
concerned with but I must point out that
Trump has been extremely cagey about
mentioning military aspect with China
because all chant Trump's comment has
been that Chinese are ripping us by
their exports and we should impose you
know huge tax on their import but when
he's asked how are you going to stop the
Chinese in expanding in South China Sea
he said we will leverage or economic
power and in his one and only foreign
policy speech he did not touch the
question of south china sea power he
only mentioned thread so I don't think
Trump is interested in military solution
tissues he's interested in he is a
negotiator he also negotiate a deal
which would you know improved US
position but I don't think Trump is
going to be providing a strategy to deal
with China I think strongly thank you
I'd now like to introduce the bravest
person in the room how long whom I first
met at the National Institute for South
China Sea studies when I was working on
my book in 2012 and is now based in the
u.s. working with the Institute for US
China studies and do you still have a
National Institute send the affiliation
not not anymore what okay well thank you
for Yahoo niversity to our increment in
this panel and being the last one to
stay in this podium I apologize to stand
between you and the dinner of the long
day discussion and thank you for putting
me this hat of being brave so I have
three are very general observation
throughout the whole optional discussion
so the first observations about China's
row because all the five presentation
touch a pound what is China has been
doing what is in row and so my i whizzed
up by commenting on general Shaffers
presentation and there is assumption
you're saying with China clams of South
China Sea as territory see and I have to
say I disagree with you but if you saw
it that you have these the assumption
and territory absolutely chas China has
never planned the South China Sea as
territory let me give you one very
concrete example let's take the
navigational regime for the total sea or
the country exercise innocent passage
but II they were talking about
navigation regime of freedom navigation
so let me take like us increasing
military power in the South China Sea so
what China days protest and but it
actually whispered and does not actually
arouse any provocative countermeasures
that actually shows that we are actually
on the same page of talk about freedom
navigation and Chinese protest is more
politically or strategically driven
rather than legally driven and and also
i think professor terror and armor or
share for share identical observation
about compared with living resources now
sources knows one with the navigation
security of seed line mechanic ation I
think both of you actually put the
strategy as one of the fundamental or
almost problem for China and I think
that's quite a fair observation and that
your your tooth observation also bring
me back to Professor Alan see she has a
very good term to describe what's
happening now in a socialist which is
the security dilemma we see it's like
psycho when the you are trying to start
a land reclamation and then we see us
more and more us engagement and then
when you ask are sending more meditative
vessels and also calling all these
original states and also countries from
outside with others region for joint
mega temperature and there were actually
a debate or given Chinese China's
government another motivation to
increase not from the land reclamation
activity but increase in military
facility construction so I can see it as
security dilemma and back to the issue
of length nation I agree with and
professor Tyler this is not a proper
phrase to describe what is actually
what's happening in that and I don't
actually also i'm not really also happy
about the world artificial islands very
technical issue so let me just use our
very made me a more neutral phrase to
describe it which i say maybe we can use
artificial construction i think your
observation about whatever we call it i
think about the function of these
features construction the features
overestimation and first of all i think
no matter how big or how strong or this
limitation of artificial islands there
and will not help country china we're
not happy to consolidate its territorial
claims so the semitic claim has to be
based on the principle of territory
equation under customary international
law so an artificial island if you want
to use your face will not have a country
to claim
consolidates territory claims it will
not actually enhance a country's marital
entitlement and have will not have any
impact on the future marathon gene
mutation and this is a legally our
explanation about a legal implementation
of those ten reclamation artificial
islands and also about what are the
military functional capacity I also
think it's over estimations a very cool
I attend one of a conference on April 14
organized by MBR and also us Japan's as
a cop I peace foundation and USA the
Vice armor from the United States Navy
Vice armor robot thomas who is the
director of office of the chief for
naval operation and he has a quite a
fair observation i think the media
coverage and all these assumption for
American scholars on government
officials from the Navy's I think their
assumption of what will be China what is
capacity especially military capacity
arising from Adam recognition in a
socialist is over etch rate
overestimated and then about a level
Commission I think I'm quite happy with
mr. Harry kiss owners and you have a lot
of strategy and I think I'm I totally
agree with you your last one is on green
key strategy and having stepped have
explained Chinese legal basis for its
elimination in a South China Sea and
there's something that I really want to
emphasize about the environmental impact
assessment which is something that
trying to need to do and Chinese
government clearly has done and pre the
granulation also post reclamation
measures in terms of maritime protection
environment protection by things very
important for China to release those IA
environment impact assessment report and
make it as transparent as possible and
then the other the second observation is
about stakeholders in Salinas ashiana
sea and hairy ball about talk about a
u.s. role in a social i see i think
that's
very important topic in terms of when we
are talking about different stakeholders
in stock in a South China Sea we're not
talking about only the Kremlin States
American Japan India Australia they all
have their digits nuh inches in a south
of the sea so the us-china relations in
the South China Sea it's very
interesting development which we see the
development from the South China Sea
dispute from are purely legal debate
with Gina Clement States over
sovereignty issues and over marathon t
mutation issues towards your political
competition between the two countries
let me tell us and china has two
examples which represent to interest
group in the lava sea convention
negotiation and actually the two country
representative interest group rd rising
from the torture murmuring liberal
hubris torture so both country China as
a clam estate has this logistic interest
of the territory a marathon clams and us
as users day and also has its creatures
my interests of securing its 3d
navigation I think there's more common
interest in difference between the two
countries that we can actually look
forward to having a increasing or a
constructive role play by the United
States in helping managing the South
China Sea and also the stakeholder
there's also other like aaron has
brought for about the trilateral
relations between China us and also the
Philippine I think you used she use a
very good work contrary to describe
actually the very complex city of the
Charlotte or relations where we have
this bilateral Clemens days and also
external States as a as a user state em
and the another layer of stakeholders in
the social niceties basically of between
or among all these Clement States I
think to be honest all these clement
states where everyone's child in your
own story turning all their own history
about telling their own evidence or
without listening to each other and I
think there's something that we need to
actually we need to be our face
same with and dr. cha has a very good
explanation of he has three publication
about others in that to show the Vietnam
screams over the peristyle and sparkly
and those those evidence and you can
also find very similar argument from the
Chinese literature on from the
Philippines literature's but I'm happy
that he told me during a coffee break he
said he has a neighbor now in y'all who
is a Chinese scholar who is also working
on collecting the Chinese evidence to
show that Chinese clamps over
sovereignty issues and also professor
knowing our last speaker from Mayor
University I think he helped us
understand issues of our relationship
between the climate states from a very
interesting angle and about the u.s.
other Vietnam and trainer relations and
I want to share with you we have very
similar observation in China how the
citizens or the population look at that
you are the China Vietnam relations and
many of like the notches ins the edge
inclusion of government that we should
not step down step back and we should be
tougher with of anemones neighbors and
one of the other this is one of another
example to show that all the clement
state actually is having their own
having their own story but this is about
a bad thing but I think we should not
let those bad stories overshadow the
positive deposit development a sociology
if we take train and VIN numbers on one
example despite all these differences
and despite all these overlapping claims
we do have very good examples of land
boundary delimitation demarcation
history and we do have a very other
firstmerit intimidation and bother you
car honking through many years about how
to negotiation and West you add process
of continuing the negotiation in the
delimitation outer mouseup ballpark of
talking so
really thinking with you or discolored
dialogue we should continue that part of
constructive engagement and dialogue and
my last observation is about this is
about as Alan has raised in
representation what we should actually
are looking at what there is the most
particle or perm attic approach to solve
the sociology disputes I think our panos
sort of a weight race different
alternatives or options like hairy
Buffalo deserve fair strategy a basket
escape strategy and then also
professional talk about the value of
third-party compulsory jurisdiction or
arbitration we don't want to play down
or or under under my the value of the
party form of third-party compulsory
dispute settlement mechanisms we talk
about ICJ we talk about the
international terminal of the sea we
talk about that arbitration as
arbitration tribunal but in terms of all
these issues and we also consider what
might be the impact arising from the
third party forum meet mechanisms did
something I want to our savory for my
tomorrow presentation because I'm
running up time and the last opportunity
or a does option that I think i would
like to echo arena suggestion may be a
way of patchy for instance a lot of
issues that we might look into like fish
oil corporation or environmental
cooperation there was a lot of
eternities or proposed to review the
post arbitration or the poster the new
development in the South China Sea so I
hope that I'm breathing of two
you